[Music]
for over 21 years now the world's most
famous sponge has been entertaining not
only children but also adults worldwide
with this uncomplicated humor
after it became known some time ago that
with camp corel for a spin-off about
spongebob's youth is already in the
works
spongebob sidekick patrick star will be
dedicated a separate series
according to an insider of deadline the
series will be called the patrick star
show and will be homage to the larry
sanders show from the 90s
with this the scatterbrain starfish will
become the host of his own late night
show when another aspect should not be
neglected
namely patrick's family of course other
characters of the spongebob franchise
will most likely also appear in the 13
planned episodes
a release date for the patrick show is
unfortunately not fixed at this time
after screenwriter derek colston
recently commented on the future of the
john wick franchise it is now officially
known there will also be a fifth part of
the john
wick franchise deadline reported by
referring to lionsgate the film is
planned to be shot after zhang week 4 as
soon as keanu reeves is available in
early 2021.
lionsgate ceo john feldheymer also
announced that the fourth film will be
released on memorial day weekend in 2022
besides the plan the continental series
now even three
john wick productions are in the process
which fans can look forward to
after many fans have been relatively
optimistic about the avatar live
action adaptation of netflix lately
great disappointment is now emerging the
original creator do michael dente
martino and brian konitsko were highly
respected among fans
announced their withdrawal from the
netflix series a few days ago
the controversial thing is that the two
have by no means withdrawn tacitly but
have settled up with the streaming
service in an open letter
so the two wrote that they were
originally full of hope when they joined
the project in 2018 as showrunners and
producers because they thought they
could realize their vision for the
renegation but at the end of the day
this was not the case
the rest of the sentences also sound
anything but conciliatory which is why
many fans now blame netflix for the exit
the streaming service will have to
process this news first because the
original series
avatar has been ranked last month in the
usa as content that has stayed the top
10 for the longest time it seems that
netflix has pushed the stakes too high
and has not given the creators the
necessary freedom it will be exciting to
see whether netflix will continue to
hold onto the project under different
management or whether the damage caused
by the departure of dimartino and
konicko is now too great
due to the pandemic we will not be able
to attend any major conventions like the
comic con this year in the last week
some alternatives have emerged which can
be followed not only
free of charge but also comfortably from
your own living room
one of them is the 24-hour event dc
fandom on august 22nd
various trailers films in series with
their own panels and more can be
expected
among others you can look forward to
news from the batman
wonder woman 1984 aquaman and also black
adam
in addition dwayne the rock johnson
wrote a tweet a few days ago with a
short black animore fandom sneak peek
johnson can also be seen briefly as a
kind of motion capture figure standing
in the ruins of a temple
almost the same video but with batman
theme was also presented to us by
director matt reeves and the first title
logo of this suicide squad can be seen
on james gunn's twitter channel
for the batman as well as for the
suicide squad we assume that there will
be new information
up-to-date pictures and maybe even a
short teaser trailer
what's also rumored is that we can
expect a second trailer for wonder woman
1984
and zack snyder also announced that we
will see a trailer for his justice
league snyder cut for the first time
as you can already see the fandom will
not lack in thematic variety and we're
looking forward to the impressive lineup
of top
class guests will you also be
participating live at the fandom on
august 22nd
write it down in the comments a few days
ago deadline reported that there is now
finally a candidate for the new tron
part he's called garth davies and is
said to have convinced the responsible
people at disney to entrust him with
this important task
davis has so far been able to convince
mainly with smaller productions like the
multiple oscar-nominated lion
tron eras will certainly not be an easy
task for the director
after all the franchise can look back on
the cult film tron from 1982 and the
sequel tron legacy from 2010
after the decision was made three years
ago to create a new tron as a kind of
reboot
nothing happened for a long time this
will now change with the engagement of
davies as director and jared leto as
actor
and producer however according to the
usual industry magazines the green light
has not yet been given
as the existing script by jessie wigato
still has to be completed and further
developed
the title tron aerys was by the way
published by later on twitter but he
already deleted this post again and
wrote tweets without
a specific title we are curious who else
will be brought on board and hope we can
announce the official start of
production
soon the first two jurassic world parts
brought in fantastic
box office takings of around 3 billion
us dollars which is why the main focus
of director colin trevorov is now
naturally on a third part that is as
successful as possible
on twitter jurassic outpost has now
published a new picture of the set which
shows clear reference to jurassic park
2.
you can see a refrigerated container in
which a valuable cargo stored according
to the inscription
in addition the logo of john hammond's
biotech company
engine can be seen with the words side b
or illusorna below it
indicating the location of the second
jurassic park part at that time
many dinosaurs without teeth left in
sight b by next year at the latest with
the release we might finally find out
what happened on the island after the
third part
after all the jurassic world movies are
playing on illa nubla
jurassic world dominion is expected to
be released in cinemas on june 11
[Music]
2021
[Music]
bye